A ONE-YEAR-OLD SITTING IN A
STROLLER SHOT AND KILLED.
CHILDREN IN THEIR OWN HOMES,
THEIR OWN BEDS, A PLACE THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT T ARE SHOT
AND KILLED BY CRIMINALS WHO
DON'T DESERVE TO BREATHE THE
SAME AIR WE DO.
AND A 4-YEAR-OLD GIRL SHOT ON
HER WAY TO A TOY STORE IN TIMES
SQUARE.
IN CITIES ACROSS AMERICA POLICE
ARE BEING HANDCUFFED, DEFUNDED,
DEMORALIZED, AND TOLD TO STAND
DOWN.
ORDERED NOT TO ARREST.
IF THEY DO, THE SWINGING DOOR OF
NO BAIL LETS THE CRIMINAL OUT TO
REOFFEND.
PROSECUTORS FUNDED BY GEORGE
SOROS ARE ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
THEY DO NOTE TAKE THE MANTEL OF
VICTIMS.
THEY SPEND THEIR TIME REFUSING
TO PROSECUTE CRIME AND RELEASE
CRIMINALS FROM PRISON.
THEIR REFORM IS FOG BUT A
EUPHEMISM.
EVEN THE TITLE, IT'S THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHEN IT
SHOULD BE THE VICTIM JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THE VICTIM.
THE ONE WHO NEVER CHOSE TO BE
PART OF THE SYSTEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
PARENTS SEEKING TO PROTECT THEIR
CHILDREN ARE I AM POTENT AGAINST
A FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WHO
SEEK TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AND
EMPOWER THEMSELVES.
WHEN THEY FINALLY SHOW UP TO
TEACH OUR CHILDREN, THEY TEACH
THEM TO BECOME LITTLE MARXIST
ACTIVISTS.
THEY ARE SO WOKE THEY SEEK TO
ALLOW STUDENTS TO DETERMINE
THEIR SEX BASED ON HOW THEY FEEL
WHICH IS HOW A 15-YEAR-OLD BOY
IN LOUDOUN COUNTY WEARING A
SKIRT WAS ABLE TO RAPE AND
SODOMIZE A 9th GAIT GIRL IN
THE BATHROOM.
WHEN THE FATHER TRIED TO VOICE
HIS OPINION AT A SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING ON ALLOWING TRANSGENDER
STUDENTS INTO THE STUDENT'S
BATHROOMS.
HE WAS ARRESTED AND CALLED A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST, THEN MADE
INTO A POSTERBOARD THAT PROVIDED
THE RADICAL ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND WITH THE BASIS HE USED
TO DEPLOY NATIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THE FBI AGAINST
PARENTS IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE BORDER.
WE DON'T SCREEN THEM OR VET
THEM.
WHO AMONG THEM IS A CRIMINAL?
WHO AMONG THEM IS A GANG FLEB?
WHO IS A PEDESTRIAN FILE?
WHO IS A SEX OFFENDER?
WHO HAS AN ALCOHOL PROBLEM, A
DRUG PROBLEM?
WHO LIKES TO DRIVE DRUNK AND HAS
NO PROBLEM HAULING DRUGS FOR THE
CARTEL.
WE AMERICANS ARE LEFT TO
EXPERIENCE THIS OURSELVES
BECAUSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
LIES AND SAYS THE BORDER IS
CLOSED.
1.7 MILLION HAVE ENTERED SINCE
JANUARY AND COUNTLESS MORE
HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN COUNSEL.
HAVE YOU HAD ENOUGH?
ARE YOU DISGUSTED YET?
I WILL TELL YOU IT JUST GOT
WORSE IN NEW YORK CITY WITH A
LEFTIST RADICAL MAYOR OFFERING
$1,000 A MONTH TO CRIMINALS TO
NOT COMMIT A CRIME.
SAN FRANCISCO IS NOT PROSECUTING
ANY CRIME UNDER $950, FORCING
SCORES OF WALGREENS DRUG STORES
TO CLOSE.
NOW THEY ARE STEALING FROM CARS.
WHERE THEY SMASH WINDOWS KNOWING
THEY WILL NEVER BE ARRESTED SOW
THEY CAN KEEP DOING IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
IN ATLANTA TWO DAYS AGO, CRIME
WITNESSES VIDEOTAPE INSTEAD OF
CALLING 911 WHERE A HOMICIDE
OCCURRED.
WE ARE THE GREATEST NATION ON
EARTH AND WE ARE QUICKLY
BECOMING LIKE A THIRD WORLD
NATION.
WEEK THANK THE DEMOCRATS, JOE
BIDEN AND THE LEFTIST MAYORS FOR
ALLOWING THE CRIME TO GO
UNPUNISHED.
WE CANNOT SURVIVE AS A NATION
MUCH LONGER WITH THIS KIND OF
ASSAULT ON OUR CITIZENS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE ANSWER TO THE
HISTORIC INCREASE IN CRIME AND
THE BREAKDOWN OF MORALS IN OUR
SOCIETY THAT LEADS TO PEOPLE NOT
CARING ABOUT ONE ANOTHER.
DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORT A LEFTIST,
MARXIST, SOCIALIST AGENDA, THE
ONES WHO DON'T CARE ABOUT US
HAVE TO BE THROWN OUT OF OFFICE.
IT'S TIME TO TAKE CRIME
PERSONALLY.
IT'S TIME TO GET ANGRY ABOUT
CRIME.
IF WE DON'T, WE'LL PROVE ABRAHAM
LINCOLN RIGHT WHEN HE SAID
AMERICA WILL NEVER BE CONQUERED
BY A FOREIGN POWER.
BUT IF WE A